[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul and today we're bringing
you a breakdown Fit For A King with our
Crown season 5 ending explained it's
back baby another season is getting
lower reviews than normal I thought it
was a great trip down memory lane the
season releases in the wake of the
Queen's death with King Charles now on
the throne this is actually a motif that
pretty much becomes the backbone of the
season and in it we watch people discuss
if Elizabeth is still fit to rule whilst
Charles and Diana fracture even further
it's been confirmed for a while now that
her death will take place in season six
with that centering around the final few
weeks of her life and the aftermath of
it that's been confirmed to be the final
season with the show's Creator saying
that he initially only wanted to do five
Peter Morgan has since said though that
it was too much to cover and this
Netflix gave the go-ahead for a 6-1 to
close it out if you're like me 34 in a
YouTuber then you you get off my patch
but you also will probably remember
where you were when you learned that
Diana died I went to my mate James
Thompson's house and we were told by his
mum which is something that stuck with
me ever since it happened the series of
course knows where it's going but what
it does is that it fleshes out the
relationship between Charles and Diana
including the infamous Martin Boucher
interview whereas Diana is thought of
being a saint and I have to confess I've
always been on her side the crown
actually tries to show things from
Charles's I hope Charles doesn't
introduce new treason laws for me saying
that but it's an interesting take to
actually go against the grain with this
now the opening episode is called Queen
Victoria's syndrome and this has a Grana
meaning over the season in literal terms
this refers to the hemophilia B that
Queen Victoria was a carrier of she
passed this trait onto three of her
children and has suddenly a pole died
from Hemorrhage when he was 30 years old
however here it's used more
metaphorically to discuss an aging
Monarch that should stand to the side
the queen seems out of touch and whilst
Britain is going through economic
turmoil she's asking for money to update
the Royal yacht it's obviously extremely
relevant right now and Not only was it
suggested that the Queen's coronation
cost the taxpayer turn but her funeral
did too all of this happened in the air
in which Britain is facing financial
crisis after financial crisis and
because of this Charles has said his
coronation next year will be toned down
you've had several things like this
happen over the last couple of decades
with refurbishments on Buckingham Palace
and so on and so forth knowing this
whilst watching the series makes it
really relevant right now and we're left
questioning whether she should step to
the side or not Charles has an interview
in episode 5 in which he wants to unite
all faiths but Elizabeth sees the crown
as being that symbol the monarchy isn't
as popular as it used to be though and
the queen is very much sticking with
Traditions whilst Charles wants to take
things in a New Direction his work on
the prince's trust allows a lot of
disadvantaged youths to Showcase their
talents and he started his own core to
lay the groundworker when he takes over
as we now know the queen ruled until her
dying day but it was really interesting
watching this discussion from the auth
through a conquer Universal Sunday Times
article it's rumored that Charles wanted
his mother to abdicate the throne during
the 90s in favor of him however due to
the divorce he became deeply unpopular
the queen basically doesn't fully trust
Charles to the point where she thinks he
can be put in charge and even with the
damning article she refuses to hand
things over the idea of things being
passed over is reflected in a lot of the
Season too with John Major playing a big
part as well he was beaten by Tony Blair
in 1997 and early on wrestles with
granting funding for the Britannia so
that they can put in some new Alexa's in
a flat screen it's also Merida Muhammad
and Dodi a ladder of which we now died
with Diana in that fatal car crash
Muhammad's acquisition of Harrods and
him slowly trying to either Royals also
plays out early on in the season now
Dodie wants to buy a home in Malibu but
his father instead lectures him about
his future which we of course know as
cut short the theme of the season is
very much about the characters putting
trust in their children and about
whether they can actually take over or
not and this video is sponsored by
established titles a fun and novel way
to preserve the natural Woodlands of
Scotland while helping Global
reforestation efforts establish titles
lets you call yourself a lady Lord or a
LED due to a traditional Scottish custom
you see landowners used to refer to
themselves as this and established
titles allows you to buy at least one
square foot of dedicated land and a
private estate in edleston Scotland on
top of this it's a great way to help out
the environment as established titles
for planetary with every single order
they work with global Charities like one
tree planet and trees for the future to
help with reforestation efforts so if
you pick up a plot you can refer to
yourself as a lord whilst also helping
to preserve the picturesque Woodlands of
Scotland and it also comes with a bit of
an ego boost on top of all this
environmental stuff you can officially
change your name on credit cards plane
tickets your dating profile whatever you
want they also give you certificate
confirming your Lord's ship and a unique
Platinum that confirms your exact plot
of land but before Kevin's spoilers you
punk I am the Lord of this realm now in
addition to this established titles have
also told me that the first 200 people
who use my link in the description below
will be given a plot within walking
distance of mine it makes an amazing
last minute gift and established titles
is actually running a massive Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code heavy spoilers you get an
additional 10 off go to
establishtitles.com heavy spoilers to
get your gifts now and help support the
channel thanks now the wild card in all
of this is Diana who at this point in
her life felt like she'd been brushed
under the rug she ends up talking to
book authors and also journalists most
notably Martin beshear these interviews
were a complete bombshell at the time
with Diana openly discussing her failed
marriage for the world to see the BBC
Panorama show attracted 23 million
viewers in the UK alone and it was
extremely eye-opening this had a
two-fold effect due to the subject
matter discussed in it and also the fact
that she was a member of the royal
family at the time they were thought to
be basically people that should embody
the keep calm common carry-on mentality
never talking with journalists unless
it's a PR approved statement episode 2
even ends with Prince Philip going to
Diana to express just how important
confidentiality is within the family
it's a great scene in which he basically
breaks down how the royal family is a
system even calls the Queen the boss
which is a nickname that we know she had
rather than being a mother and
grandmother she's seen as a leader a
sort of corporate figurehead who keeps
the business and the people within it in
line so that's why Diana's discussion
was so controversial whether it also had
the mental health aspect that came with
it though there is still some stigma
attached to it mental health issues are
talked about far more openly now than
they were back then Diana being a royal
family member and talking about her
mental health struggles like this rock
the boat or or yacht quite a lot now in
the aftermath of bishir's interview we
have some extra controversy that's come
with it in 2020 the BBC director General
Tim Davey apologized to Diana's family
for the use of fake bank statements
which were used to really Diana into
thinking a certain way this is shown in
episode 7 with Bashir forging documents
and showing them to die on his brother
created by a graphic designer these were
used to indicate that people had been
paid to spy on Diana which apparently
made her want to strike back and carry
out the interview he turned Diana's
driver friends and also brother against
her in order to get an interview on
bonfire night which symbolically has
this idea of trying to ouster our family
a paranoia is something we see
throughout the season with her
constantly listening to hear if she can
hear people tapping her phone lines this
continuous second guessing was
weaponized against her and it allowed
Bashir to gain unrivaled access is also
seen in which the brakes and hikar fail
which is obviously a bit on the nose
foreshadowing either way though it
builds a sense within her that she needs
to do something an inquiry was carried
out in 96 that apparently cleared Bashir
of wrongdoing and this made it seem like
that would be all there was however Earl
Spencer rejected the apology and said
that he actually had documents which
proved this year had lied these
documents had been used to trash the
royal family and the defamatory pieces
were said to be the key to getting Diana
to do the tell-all an independent
inquiry was launched but at the time
Bashir said he was seriously ill so the
investigation was postponed Bashir
resigned in 2021 and the police
announced they wouldn't do a critical
investigation however it was still found
that Bashir was devious and dishonest
which in the report were the words used
to describe him devious and dishonest
journalists say well I never the guy
doesn't come out looking good and he
constantly says don't trust anyone
whilst filling her head with lies there
were also wild rumors brought up
including that Charles had had an affair
with their child's Nanny the BBC ended
up paying her an undisclosed sum and
damages and the interview is seen as
being highly controversial for not only
its content but also for its aftermath
similar to the idea of the old God
Passing Over Control he also watches the
new head of the BBC wants to modernize
the company the older one just wants to
keep up tradition and again there's this
constant wrestling back and forth about
whether the interview should be public
either way this was an earth-shattering
Revelation and it changed the world the
controversy is married and Charles and
Camilla who too have a phone call
recorded that gets passed to journalists
it flies under the radar for years
before being released and this is the
start of Tampax gate it's the most
highbrow phone sex you've ever heard
with them saying they adore each other
in between the oof suits you sir
now that raised doubts over whether
Charles could be king and then when the
Diana interview dropped it just the
latest plans to take over it's very much
an example how there's almost a double
stand with things as Charles's interview
about the divorce in episode 5 it is
pretty much seen as fair game or as hers
isn't if air Rock the family and at the
time it was thought that's something
like this would never happen or we make
it seem that Prince Charles has had an
affair outside of marriage and therefore
would have to divorce
Diana was off doing her own thing too
and she had her own Soulja Boy in haznak
Khan the latter had a two-year
relationship with her and was described
as being her soul mate It All Leads to
this very public and very messy divorce
in episode 9 is very much about Charles
handling that alongside Camilla
strategically they try and do the
opposite of what Diana did and keep very
quiet about their personal affairs this
episode is beautifully shot and
throughout it we see couples chronicling
their divorce whilst all this is going
on episode 9 very much shows that they
still have respect for each other and it
deals with a pair discussing their
marriage whilst in their old home it's
sort of the last day of their marriage
with Diana finally acknowledging Camilla
through using her name these moments are
very much a time lapse of their marriage
with a scene the good and happy times
initially before it devolves into the
dark ones from here we cut to episode 10
and this is titled decommissioned now
this reflects a number of things in the
finale the Tories are voted out of power
after suffering their worst loss in
recent memory the Royal yacht becomes
New Britain Hong Kong is given
Independence the marriage is over and
Dury's idea of moving to La is something
his father's fully against the queen
feels like she's being decommissioned
along with the yacht and we watches the
one strong and stable family starts to
fall apart Charles goes against his
mother viewing the yacht as having its
own Queen Victoria syndrome which should
be left in the past Tony talks about how
the queen has a veto over who Charles
can marry and this is of course also
reflected in Dowdy this is coupled with
a monarchy debate and we see Diana
basically hitting the dislike button
from her burner account this opening
shows how she's still very much against
the Royals and hella weight off her
shoulders hasn't really lifted she's
chased through the street by Paparazzi
again foreshadowing the Fate that lies
ahead of her in Paris Diana thought she
could leave the Royal Family behind but
she still found herself inside the
trappings of it as one yard is shut down
we see another as Muhammad travels out
on his the end has the queen looking
dowley to the feature with her son very
much hammering home that he should be
leading however she sees this as being a
job that one has to do until the day
they die her being on the ship at the
end shows how she's very much stuck in
the past and also in this mind State now
Diana is supposed to represent someone
slightly more optimistic even though
she's been stuck in the aftermath of the
divorce we end with her prepping her
trip to Santa pay which is of course
gonna be some quality time with William
and Harry organized by Muhammad this
became a fateful journey in which he
grew closer to Dodie she then journeyed
out to Holiday with the family again and
on the yacht they sailed to the south of
France before they eventually traveled
to Paris this led to the Fateful car
crash that killed a pair on August 31st
which we know will be a major event in
season six with it being so close to the
ending timeline wise I think it might
end up happening earlier on in the
season potentially even in the first
couple of episodes this massively rocked
the royal family and it was at a time
where doubt against their actions was
definitely out of tires now if you want
a great time caps you'll love the
aftermath of this then I highly
recommend you check out the Queen's
starring Helen Mirren it goes over her
death and also the Fallout from it dub
the people's Princess Diana's funeral
was a highly televised event that saw a
great wave of mourning washing over the
country at this time as well the
Windsors were also worried that Blair's
modernization mentality might take them
out too it was definitely a time of
inaction with the Royals due to Diana's
death and when she passed away they
stayed pretty tight-lipped about it for
some time the public mourned and their
silence became even more deafening the
longer that they refused to acknowledge
anything about it but in the end they
did and though it was late it was
greatly appreciated Blair definitely
became bolstered up during this time
however we now know from our own history
that his popularity didn't last long and
the queen movie ends with her warning
him that just in the same way the public
turned against the Royals that they
could also do it against him we know
this will come to pass and currently at
least remind point of view blast dance
is a very unpopular figure I feel like
all these events will very much play out
in the next season and we know from
leaks on the series that next time we'll
showcase the meeting between Prince
William and Kate Middleton this season
made it clear that the pressure of
succession was getting to him too and it
also hints that we could be getting
further time jumps are they met in 2001
whereas Diana died in 97 so we have at
least a four year time Jump going on
here we also have the Queen's golden
jubilee and this happened in 2002 this
was a major year for the monarchy with
both the Queen Mother and Princess
Margaret dying with six being the last
season though I think we have to end on
a more positive node and we may see the
marriage of Camilla and Charles the last
few seasons had a heavy focus on their
relationship and after years of being
told no they finally tied the knot I
think with Charles now becoming the king
in real life they need to put a focus on
that and going forward I can't see that
being the way the sixth season plays out
as for this one I thought it sort of
felt like like a middle ground that
connected four to six but there were
still a lot of major events covered here
the Martin beshear interview was a major
crisis for the Royals I thought it
played out so well in the series with us
seeing the inner workings of it through
not only Diana but also the BBC we also
had some really nice touches with things
like Sydney Johnson getting a full
inclusion and some very grounded and
stuck performances at times I got lost
in how much Elizabeth debicky was
nailing Diana and she perfectly captured
her mannerisms coupled with the costumes
on her I feel like this was a home run
for the most important person that they
had to get right in the series now I
kind of feel like Dominic West was was
sort of just doing a Dominic West and no
I don't think he was bad or anything I
don't really think he embodied Charles
same sort of thing with the queen too
and it's interesting I think how the
reception of the show might have played
out had she still been alive she doesn't
exactly come across well here but the
show is of course Very reliant on Gossip
Blair's spokesperson even released
statements saying that his talks with
Childs were absolute works of fiction so
yeah when you're watching this you know
what we say at the channel take it with
a pinch of salt however it is still good
fiction and the drama here is so well
constructed and delivered I really
appreciate how they create thematic
elements from real life history and
seeing the metaphor of the royal yacht
which also showed the Queen's Reign was
an inspired way to take things it's
another solid season that doesn't quite
capture all the highs of the previous
entries but it's still a good one that I
think is worth your time now I live in
South Shields and they mention it at one
point in the series so I'm giving it a
10 out of 10. shields on my back like
Captain America never given it lower
than that no obviously go in with my
heart and my head though I think I'm
gonna go with a 7.5 now obviously I
would love to hear your thoughts do you
agree with me do you not make sure you
comment below and let me know we are in
a competition right now giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the season
you pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the last ones are
on screen right now so that's you then
message me on Twitter at heavy spoilers
if you want something else to watch
we've got a video on screen right now
that YouTubers chosen specifically for
you so yeah go check that out right now
otherwise I'm kicking off you still here
so I'm angry come on get yourself over
there and I hope you enjoy the rest of
your week you take care yourself mate
thanks for sending me through the video
peace